es la semana de la guerra para rusia han
comenzado sus juegos militares donde
participan una treintena de países como
venezuela que participa desde 2015 y
este año por primera vez es anfitrión de
una categoría este lunes se inauguró la
competencia de francotiradores
por supuesto abrazamos a todas las
naciones sus participantes sus
delegaciones sus representaciones que
han venido a venezuela a competir en
buena lid en el marco de estos juegos
internacionales rusia 2022 en el mismo
día el presidente de rusia vladimir
putin también inauguró el foro armia
2022 es la mayor feria de material
militar ruso donde se pueden encontrar
más de 28.000 tipos diferentes de
armamento
putin envió un mensaje para armar
américa latina' gato pérez wasit ayude
estamos listos para ofrecer a nuestros
aliados y socios los tipos de armas más
modernos desde armas de infantería hasta
vehículos blindados pasando por
artillería aviación de combate o drones
trata de atraer a países de américa
latina el considerado como patio trasero
de eeuu el objetivo no explicó a france
24 carlos molina ex director de
armamento y electrónica de la armada
venezolana y ha dicho públicamente
que putin él quiere cambiar el mundo y
hacerlo multipolar los expertos avisan
de que el armamento ruso no está
pudiendo en ucrania con las lanzaderas
de misiles estadounidenses ni los
blindados antiaéreos alemanes por lo que
una hipotética compra de armamento ruso
respondería más a motivos geopolíticos
que de eficiencia militar
[Música]